the police in the French Capital have
raided the headquarters of the Paris
2024 Olympic Committee this follows a
report from the anti-corruption agency
of potential irregularities they also
searched the organizing committee's
office that oversees construction sites
Natasha Butler joins me now from Paris
Natasha this could potentially be a very
big deal in terms of France's image
politically perhaps what more do you
know at this stage
well according to France's Financial
prosecutor police and investigators
raided these two offices the officers of
paris's Olympics organizing committee
and another company called solido that
works in construction and has been
helping to build some of the sites and
the infrastructure associated with the
Olympics now we understand that these
raids are connected with two
investigations one that was launched in
2017 even before Paris actually won its
bid for the Olympics and the other in
2022 and both for those investigations
are linked to allegations of Corruption
of embezzlement of public funds and
favoritism but that's all we know for
now
Natasha how's the preparation for these
games coming along we're just over a
year from The Game's opening
just over a year and in fact the
international organizing committee the
ioc are actually meeting uh for two days
to discuss uh the preparations and the
progress here in Paris it is uh of
course progressing we're and as you say
just over one year away from the
Olympics and the Paralympics will be
taking place between July and September
in 2024 so far A little bit over budget
some 10 billion dollar 10 billion
dollars uh I should say has been spent
but costs have been limited because many
of the venues and the locations being
used for the sports already exist so for
example where I'm standing at the foot
of the Eiffel Tower there's a large Park
and that's going to become the venue for
the beach volleyball the river sen that
runs through the center of Paris just
behind the Eiffel Tower also well that's
going to be used for many water sports
including diving so no doubt it will be
spectacular France is very used to
hosting these sort of large
International world events from the Tour
de France each year also got the Rugby
World Cup coming up later this year so
there is excitement amongst people who
enjoy Sport and enjoy these sort of
events but there are also others in
France who are increasingly saying that
there is no real place for these kind of
big International sporting events that
cost so much money and have such a large
social environmental impact uh on the
countries they're in and and elsewhere
people saying that look we should
actually be spending this money on other
things and limiting the sort of social
environment environmental impact that we
see attached to things like the Olympics
so divided opinions as ever uh on big
events like the Olympic Games
Natasha Butler reporting from the foot
of the Eiffel Tower in Paris thank you
very much